[Music]
welcome back to the AT&T Pebble Beach
pro-am joining us now is Wayne Gretzky
will get to play with jordan Spieth the
speech said make sure you call him doc
all of a sudden you get a doctorate wait
you got an honorary Doctorate now you're
dr. Gretzky here come on well first of
all actually it's great to be here it's
good to see you let's jump right in
heroin you know it's so funny because
I've been sitting here thinking okay how
am I gonna answers because I'm sitting
in your truck and I heard him say that I
was okay and it's the worst thing in the
world when you're ready for a question
you don't have an answer I was teasing
one day everybody called doctors bus
doctor bus and then one time I said you
know I have an honorary Doctorate also
and can anybody call me doc so the guys
to the club started calmly doc Dustin
always calls me doc and then it turned
into this now in the golf world outside
of the anything else other than the golf
world I'm known as doc and that's how I
got the name when you were growing up
aside from the great one did you have
another nickname scrat's okay when I
played junior hockey I was 14 years old
I was 122 pounds and they called me
pretzel it goes inside I break in half
so I was my nickname for about a year
did you play any other sports girl oh I
played them all I love my favorite sport
believe it or not I was baseball I
wanted to be a major league baseball
player I used to listen to Jack buck on
the radio because we got there stationed
in my hometown and the great thing about
the Cardinals was there an hour behind
so they came on at 8:30 so when I go in
it got usually went to bed around 7:30 8
o'clock I can listen to the Cardinal
game on the radio and fall asleep so I
want to be a baseball player I grew up
playing box lacrosse everyone thinks
hockey is Canada sport but box lacrosse
is our national sport
that's a tough year it's a tough sport I
grew up dreaming about competing for
Canada and the Olympic Games running in
you know 1500 meters or marathon so I
had all these aspirations and my dad
kept kind of clipping me over the head
saying you know you're a hockey player
you know
okay
so I knew I knew it at 14 or 15 I said
okay I love baseball but I'm not going
to be a professional baseball player I
better head in the direction of hockey
if you were good enough and I said you
could have played baseball or huh oh my
gosh I would have taken baseball all day
long I would have loved to vend the
shortstop for these Detroit Tigers
I grew up such a big tiger fan Ernie
Harwell and listened in Tiger games
healed about Alan Trammell dryland war
and yeah yeah all those guys I have when
Mark the bird fed Rich came out I can
remember that was when he used to be on
ABC was a Howard Cosell on the game of
the week game of the week and I'd be so
excited about watching the bird pitch
that night I thought okay this guy is so
unique and he's so good and yet he had
charisma and he had a style and the
Grace and an elegance about him and one
time remember an interview Howard Cosell
was bragging to the Yankee players
Thurman Munson Reggie Jackson all the
guys were on that team and he said you
know mark the bird federate said he's
going to mow you guys down and they were
like cutting them up you know which was
normal as a young kid and then he went
back to Mark's Idris and said you know
these guys said this while you those who
were those guys he had no idea who was
on the team he knows the New York
Yankees and I always thought that was so
fascinating
I like that Howard stirring it up yeah
lying to the Yankees and that yeah
there's Idris that's why you was so good
did you meet so she'll know and I
watched every Monday Night Football game
I used to love him on baseball you know
he was a pioneer for you guys you know
like in the that world
he was so unique I don't know how I
don't know today if he would be
acceptable how people would react to him
today you know fans are so strong so
fickle now like they they believe what
they believe and like he was a lawyer a
lawyer hands became a broadcaster well
Muhammad Ali his reaction show yeah that
hand is so unique in that they loved
each other yet hated each other and
that's what sold Howard
with criticism I handled it well in the
sense that it drove me it made me
compete harder but how did they
criticize you yes I was saying this the
other day we were talking about Bobby
Orr Connor mcDavid's and Austin Matthews
and I was saying you know those guys at
14 years old were can't-miss and then
there was a number-one pick and they
were they belong there that's absolutely
when I was 14 or 15 I was still getting
as much praise as I was getting there
was this well he's too small is too
short he's too slow is he tough enough
we don't know if he can make it so I had
this different path than Bobby Orr and
Connor McDavid had a little bit more
like Gordie Howe Gordie Howe got cut by
the New York Rangers his first training
camp now how smart are the New York
Rangers he's the greatest player ever
lived like son you can't play in this
professional hockey so I had the more
that route and that drove me today is
different there's so much more media and
so much more social media I don't know
how I guess you grew up with it though
you learn to accept that learned that
that's part of society but when you came
from Edmonton to Los Angeles right and
of course Janet's involved in this your
wife I can only imagine what social
media would have done Oh
first situation yeah that wouldn't have
been good they would rock you up a
little bit right yeah that wouldn't have
been good I hate to think what it would
like you know it's a different world
right you know like it's just different
today than it was back then
he's Wayne Gretzky's oh goodness I love
my wife too much I guess what are you I
know you're competitive up but did you
ever have to dislike some some guys like
that build up a rivalry you know bird
and magic oh yeah
yeah like who dislike some no no not
personally never oh you did or team we
hated the New York Islanders but we
didn't hate them as people you respect
yeah we respected them but you have to
hit your opponent ghosts different go
you know and I found that out with what
happened to dustin last year with the
unfortunate the moving of the ball yeah
and so many guys during the tournament
came out and said you know Dustin did
nothing wrong
and these guys are as competitive as
anybody they're like bird and magic like
they're competing every day and yet you
could see the respect factor and to me
and it was great that he won to me that
was one of the greatest things that
happened in that tournament was to see
everyone come out and defend Dustin and
that whether it was right wrong or
indifferent they were defending him as a
person and that's what I love the most
but you didn't like a goalie or a
defenseman who look a cheap shot like oh
yeah
Billy Smith and I hated each other yeah
and we were coaching the celebrity
all-star game throwing Justin Bieber on
the ice video and actually he's very
good I have to tell you I felt Pronger
granted yeah riding minute Lois I told
him I said when he got back to Vince I
said I give you one piece of advice
never go in the corners you get hurt
there and you can't score from there so
don't go there but Bieber had some
talent he's very good player you know he
grew up in Stratford which is 25 30
minutes of my hometown and I have a
really cute story in the sense that I
did I I went on this show a talk show
and it was his birthday and they wanted
to surprise beaver he was turning 16 I
was like well you know am i well he's
gonna do it you know I have a normal
relationship right yeah he's going to do
it so I'm like okay and so I was going
to surprise him and my daughter at the
time was eight I was going to surprise
my daughter with Justin Bieber right so
this is a perfect scenario so I walked
on my daughter froze it was like the it
was like the Cindy Brady syndrome when
the red light came on my daughter just
went No right and so I almost had to
carry her across the stage and the first
thing he said to me was you know when I
was a kid I did a tour of your basement
with my hockey team and I'm thinking my
gosh is anybody in Canada miss my
basement so your dad lets everybody oh
yeah and so he actually grew up playing
so he was a good player so I called
corner the night before I said Corner
beavers going to play we just jump in
for a shift and he goes I'll play the
whole game he's such a nice young man so
it's really I think they had fun playing
with each other
I put Eric Lindros
left wing with of I said well we need a
big dealer take care of those two kids
it was just it was a great event great
weekend it was nice as beaver came and
played it was great the corner jumped in
the Patrick Kane jumped in I was teasing
Patrick I said I'm gonna put you and
Danny Savard together finally get you
with a good sentiment why not jaws a
Dave kid yeah what's the weirdest
reaction you've gone from within
anybody cried when they meant you oh you
know yeah you know people are so loyal
such hockey fans you know for me my best
moment everybody's nice you know if this
is really you don't meet bad people they
don't want to meet you they walk away
right yeah so you're always meeting good
people
it's always nice for me when I visit
kids who are not healthy or you go to a
hospital and I know as a parent how you
feel as a parent like you just want any
kind of joy for your kids and for me
that's the most gratifying part of being
an athlete Paulie did you stock Wayne
Gretzky yeah I mean a lot of people have
about 20 years ago when you were on the
Rangers but you were walking down the
street on 76th Street in New York myself
and three buddies saw you we followed
you for about a half an hour if we went
here like a Jewish place to get a juice
we stood in line behind you this is
absolutely foreign guys are Jewish you
walked out we were too scared to say
anything to you we walked up with my
buddy goes I'll have four with the green
one I would die I loved every bargain
you know living in New York the best and
I loved every minute of it what I loved
the most about being in New York was my
wife was a bigger star in New York than
I was because flamingo kid was such a
big movie back in the early 80s that
everybody knew Janet and so wherever we
went it was like Janet Jones Janet Jones
I'm like this is wonderful like great I
was like this is perfect so when you
fall in love with her after flamingo kid
um jeez I yeah you know I saw the movie
but we we fell in love with her after
flamingo again I don't know where all
this yeah um we actually met we've met a
couple times we actually were on our
first date and a Laker Celtics
playoff game that's why we're there we
both love bird and magic we told me
there I went to the game with Alan
Thicke and she went to the game of the
friends and it was Alan Thicke said now
let's all go for bite to eat after the
game I'm like okay that sounds great to
me
and so we went for a bite to eat and a
year later we're engaged and treated and
having a baby that all happened in one
year but here you are with the old time
assist total Alan Thicke I had the
greatest ever and he always told me that
too before I let you go what makes AT&T
Pebble Beach program special for you to
make a stop yeah for me it's pretty
simple chance to spend some time quality
time with Dustin a is a friend and you
know he's just such a special young man
in our lives and most importantly he's
just so much fun to watch play and I and
I get a chance to play with J :
and Jordan speith Jordan is one of the
greatest athletes in there he's a young
new up-and-coming athlete who handles
everything with class and dignity it's
fun to be able to with that my life I'm
really no good but I tell people this
all the time when when Dustin went to
the President's Cup two years ago and
Jordan was number one in the world
Jordan said to the coach at that time I
believe was Jay Haas I want to play with
Dustin Johnson and I want to partner
with him and from that point on Dustin
Johnson became Dustin Johnson who is
today and I'm telling mr. Smith the
story he goes
darn I said told my son because his
mother so it's really exciting for me I
get to be inside the ropes and play with
two of the greatest athletes in the
world today and two of the nicest young
men you could ever meet so I just have a
lot of fun I had some bad shots night
some good shots but all in all we just
have a wonderful time and that's when I
won $30,000 yesterday each for charity
and a putting contest because it was
rainy and I'm going how great is this
golf with money standing around Lane
it's great to see and have fun all week
no place you're doing the show do it
again sometime
all right thanks guys we're back in the
dance
let's go to this the Dan Patrick show
weekday morning on audience
[Music]